I really like this car it's like so like
ah I don't know I just I just I feel
good in it you know and then I like how
it drives to Hayes here and today guys
guess what
watch me son hit us up and they were
like hey guys we want you guys check out
our brand new 2016 Nissan Altima 3.5 SL
oh my goodness we got the key so what we
are gonna do guys
today is we're gonna show you how a shag
so nuts
Nick a Nissan Altimas I am so excited
you know when I was in high school the
Altima was like my dream car I really
really really really yeah I just love
like how slick Bailey's it looks pretty
luxurious they're sitting out front all
right kind of peek through the window so
we kind of peeked and like it looks
pretty nice yeah okay I'm so excited to
show you guys you guys let's go look how
gorgeous this thing is and I love that
it happens to be the same color the car
already have oh I already know I'm
loving this color ooh this is nice oh
this is really nice oh I like the smell
in here I like smell it the new car oh
that's like my number one thing that I
love about new cars and everyone in the
JK curve always laughs because anytime
anyone and the crew has a brand new car
I immediately did Katie and I overhead
with them and then you've got
don't like now we really really gotta do
the most important thing right now what
is that breakfast no the most important
thing right now is to drive it around
the block I really want to see how
Alucard drive that eat breakfast
yes actually can I Drive it first how
would I do is a big car model girl not
so good at the be honest here that even
the lady yeah you got good taste lady
day before so Casey and I we have older
cars - mm 10 mm oh I feel like starting
2010 is when all the cars started having
like all these cool little things are
like their standard so for example my
car doesn't have seat warmers my car
doesn't have a backup camera
my car doesn't have like a touchscreen
like the thingy
like had a steering world heating up -
my hands are really cool like you turn
on the seat a steering wheel
I mean heated stereo the heated steering
wheel yes alright so now we're going to
go have breakfast and spend our day with
this Nissan Altima yay actually later on
I'm gonna have to go to a shoot um so
Casey gets to enjoy this car all to
himself for a couple hours love you and
then we're going to reconvene and then
have dinner together so that's a plan
for today
we are now one of our favorite cute
little crunchy adorable cute music
French Empire so excited and it always
looks like super beautiful with like a
work of art every time they make
all right so we're all done with lunch
and so now I got to go to my shoot
cuz I'm gonna be late and I'm gonna drop
myself off and then Casey gets to enjoy
the rest of the day with this little
beauty cuz we only have this baby from
one this car really has everything that
I'm looking for in my next part Thanks
it left it just notified me right now a
car that was in my blind spot
my car doesn't do that I want this car
so bad
do we have to do them back to me I think
you've gotten to the point where as long
as you don't name this car you're gonna
be okay
you're gonna get so attached but you're
gonna as you're taking it back tomorrow
morning you enjoy my company yeah no you
can't do that you just named it Jeffrey
I don't know the first thing that [ __ ]
you belong with them and we are here
okay baby have fun with this how will
you have fun at your shoot his car knock
them out actually bleep I have wha
you gotta go alright just got back home
and starting to rain and I was actually
planning on going to the beach to work
as I headed and I can edit just from
anywhere stop singing about got a new
car for the day - I'll live it up large
and go to the beach and the sand
sometime listen to the waves but not so
much anymore it's absolutely what's not
absolutely raining it's we got a little
sprinkle going on I just checked the
weather and I was saying that it was
going to be 70% rain in Malibu which
miles and ago and so I think we working
from home today but yeah Jeffery is
getting wet
alright it's finally time to pick up -
she is done with work we're going to be
going out for dinner tonight tonight
will be career barbecue
just pulled up back at the office when a
call tif through the Bluetooth you see
how this Bluetooth thing working good
morning hello hello it works yeah hey
TIFF yeah I'm out front around Mel I'm
out back yeah I'm outside look at that
sexy mama hey what you up to tonight
sing you a ting huh Mick you all day
today mr. Joe what did you take yeah the
car all to yourself the whole day just
trying to plan like oh cool I got this
new car today I can like pretend I'm
like someone else so I thought I'm gonna
go to the beach today and like work from
the beach somehow right and then what I
decided that next thing you know I
started sprinkling yeah raining yeah
actually rained a little bit yeah I
don't know yeah well I'm really really
hungry cuz I've been shooting all day uh
you hungry yeah and you know what though
you know what I think this car isn't
worth enjoying because you're not you're
with me oh gosh I'm just gettin outta no
darling darling now yeah but I'm really
really really hungry do anything yeah
down here baby Q all mine
okay do you remember our first date ever
yes how can I ever forget every single
time we go eat Korean barbeque I
remember our first date
story goes KPI meant it was because we
were at a rooftop party in k-town and
that's when I was like ho since we're in
k-town you want to get some Korean
barbecue and you're alive what's that
yeah I'm like what it was Korean
barbecue or what is that and you were
just like lying below that I had never
heard of this amazing uh food so yeah so
that I remember after that how you kind
of I don't know if you did this on
purpose or not but I'm pretty sure you
anything you did on purpose you can get
some credit but anyways I remember you
saying well why do you have a trick for
a barbecue man we gotta go get something
like we should just you know all go and
go eat some Korean barbecue everywhere
like what everyone was in our circle of
friends yeah everyone go and I'm like
I'm down like yeah let's do it
and that was pretty much your little
like wait my move yeah your move trying
to get me to go out on a date with you
so that was like around November and
then we never ended up going on that
date because I was already dating
someone at the time so fast forward to
May we're both single now and we end up
talking through Facebook we set up a
date which kind of unintentionally it
turned out to me because in my mind it
was just two friends going out to go eat
but in Katie's mind was I'm going on a
date don't you it he takes me to go eat
Korean barbeque for the first time in
k-town and it was awesome I fell in love
ever since then we always go meet her in
barbecue I remember there was even like
a short short time when every single
Friday we would go eat Korean barbeque
and kind of turn
so yeah I mean that night eating
Freiberg cute we were having such a
great time and that's all like that's
when we really connected it really and
then the rest was history and I work
together now we're tipping that adorable
good lover I never heard anyone tell
their own story of how they got together
and and then just comment isn't that
adorable
yeah I am cuz I think it's adorable
okay I love you I love you too baby
Shh okay we are all a big thank you to
Nissan for letting us explore this
beautiful 2016 Nissan Altima which we
had a blast driving Geoffrey around for
the whole day don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up and if you haven't
already please subscribe and um next
week bye Jeffrey Jeffrey says bye - bye
Jeffrey